is it true um that the woman who
designed this is Keana Reeves's mom yes
she did a lot of sewing for me she did a
lot of my clothes but I remember K when
he was just little and she would bring
him over to my house when we were feding
or when I would go to the shop where she
worked so and one day years and years
and years ago I was at doing a show
somewhere and somebody knocked on the
door and of course Keana was already
famous at the time he knocked on the
door and he said do you remember me I'm
the little boy that used to sit at your
feet when my mom was doing I said oh my
god of course I knew he was you know had
become a strawber it had it didn't
connect to me that that was who that was
and I heard that he wore it actually for
Halloween one year oh he did he wore
this exact outfit